I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, ladies. Hi.
我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为你制作《办公室》终极重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。嗨，女士们。嗨。
I'm sitting in a different seat today, getting sassy, mixing it up. Is it going to bring a new energy to the pod? Probably. We'll see. Is it going to give me a crick in my neck? Maybe. I know. Why did I sit here?
我今天坐在不同的位置，感觉很时髦，换换口味。这会给播客带来新的活力吗？可能会吧。我们走着瞧。这会让我的脖子落枕吗？也许吧。我知道。我为什么要坐在这里？
Well, guys, things are going to be crazy today. We're sitting in new spots. Today we're breaking down new leads, which is season six, episode 20. Lady, there's only six more episodes before we head into season seven. I can't believe it. But I want to point out we did 26 episodes in season six. That is a huge number of episodes for a television season. I know.
好吧，伙计们，今天会很疯狂。我们坐在新的位置上。今天我们要剖析《新线索》，也就是第六季第20集。女士，在进入第七季之前只剩下六集了。我简直不敢相信。但我想指出，我们在第六季拍了26集。对于一个电视季来说，这是一个巨大的集数。我知道。
We all got sick at the end. I know. We all caught a cold bug. I have a little bit of trivia for you before we even start. Really? What is it? I looked in my digital clutter. And?
我们最后都病倒了。我知道。我们都得了感冒。在开始之前，我有一点小知识要告诉你。真的吗？是什么？我在我的数字杂物里看到的。然后呢？
The original title for this episode was Scavenger Hunt. Really? Yes. The table read, it was called Scavenger Hunt. Hmm. Hmm. I'm telling you, sitting in new spots, trivia right at the top. What's next?
这一集的原始标题是《寻宝游戏》。真的吗？是的。在剧本围读时，它叫《寻宝游戏》。嗯。嗯。我跟你说，坐在新位置，一上来就是冷知识。接下来是什么？
Well, I'll tell you this episode was written by Brent Forrester and directed by Brent Forrester. I'm going to hit you with a summary now for new leads, formerly known as Scavenger Hunt. Saber's new policies favoring the sales team have caused them to become obnoxious toward their coworkers. Michael attempts to check their egos and teach humility by refusing to hand out the new sales leads. Instead, Michael gives them to the non-sales staff who hide them around the office.
好吧，我告诉你，这一集是由布伦特·福雷斯特编剧并执导的。现在我要为你总结一下《新线索》，原名《寻宝游戏》。赛博公司偏袒销售团队的新政策导致他们对同事变得令人讨厌。迈克尔试图通过拒绝分发新的销售线索来打压他们的傲气并教导他们谦逊。相反，迈克尔把线索给了非销售人员，让他们把线索藏在办公室各处。
A bunch of them end up in a dump where Michael and Dwight and Aaron and Andy further their respective relationships. He basically hid $50,000 around the office. Yeah. Oh my gosh. How is he not fired? How is he not fired? Fast fact number one is a fan question from Alexandra in Huntsville, Alabama, who said,
其中一堆最终被扔进了垃圾场，迈克尔、德怀特、艾琳和安迪在那里进一步发展了他们各自的关系。他基本上把5万美元藏在了办公室里。是啊。天哪。他怎么没被解雇？他怎么没被解雇？第一个速记事实是来自阿拉巴马州亨茨维尔的亚历山德拉的粉丝提问，她说，
What exactly are leads? Alexandra, I think this is a really good thing to start with because if we aren't clear on what a lead is, this episode is going to fall apart. It will, not to mention I counted, and we say the word leads 33 times in this episode. Wow. We really need to know what that is. I will tell you, according to Investopedia, a sales lead is a person or business who may eventually become a client.
到底什么是线索？亚历山德拉，我认为这是一个很好的切入点，因为如果我们不清楚什么是线索，这一集就会分崩离析。确实，更不用说我数过了，我们在这一集中说了33次“线索”这个词。哇。我们真的需要知道那是什么。我告诉你，根据Investopedia的说法，销售线索是指可能最终成为客户的人或企业。
Businesses gain access to sales leads through advertising, trade shows, direct mailings, third parties, and other marketing efforts. Sales people then use those leads to send sales pitch emails or direct marketing materials and to make cold calls. Now, several factors determine the quality of a sales lead, such as whether or not the individual or business had an incentive to offer their contact information. You know, like when they say, get a free steak dinner, if you listen to this sales pitch about a time share and fill out an information card.
企业通过广告、贸易展览、直接邮寄、第三方和其他营销努力获得销售线索。销售人员然后利用这些线索发送销售推介邮件或直接营销材料，并进行冷拨电话。现在，有几个因素决定了销售线索的质量，例如个人或企业是否有动力提供他们的联系信息。你知道，就像他们说的那样，如果你听这个关于分时度假的销售推介并填写一张信息卡，就能获得免费的牛排晚餐。
Those information cards would be considered leads that then a person will follow up on and try to sell you that time share. But if you got something in return, you might have just been there for the free steak dinner. So those are kind of bum leads. You know, when you take an online survey, that'll generate a sales lead. I always do the online survey. You do. You love an online survey?
那些信息卡会被视为线索，然后会有人跟进并试图向你推销那个分时度假。但如果你得到了回报，你可能只是为了那顿免费的牛排晚餐才去的。所以那些算是无效线索。你知道，当你参加在线调查时，那会产生一个销售线索。我总是做在线调查。你做。你喜欢在线调查？
I do. Oh, well, this explains my spam mail. It's very full. I was going to say, nowadays, they create sales lead by tracking your purchases online, and then you get targeted ads to watch. I'm a real sucker for those. Lady, let me tell you, I watched an episode of John Oliver about third party tracking that blew my mind.
我喜欢。哦，好吧，这解释了我的垃圾邮件。它非常满。我正想说，如今，他们通过在线跟踪你的购买行为来创建销售线索，然后你就会看到定向广告。我很容易上当。女士，让我告诉你，我看了约翰·奥利弗关于第三方跟踪的一集，让我大开眼界。
Oh, no. Oh, yeah. So when you go on a website, when you look at something, when you fill out your information, and sometimes you get a little disclaimer, like, are you okay to accept this or fill out this and you click it, if you don't read all of it, and it's a ton of tiny little words and they say a lot in there somewhere, it's like that they can then give that information, the site that you're actually interested in, like hummingbird feeders, can then give your information to maybe someone who makes mattresses, who then can give your information to someone
哦，不。哦，是的。所以当你访问一个网站，当你查看某样东西，当你填写你的信息时，有时你会得到一个小免责声明，比如，你是否同意接受这个或填写这个，然后你点击它，如果你没有读完所有内容，里面有很多微小的文字，他们在某个地方说了很多，就像他们随后可以把那个信息，你真正感兴趣的网站，比如蜂鸟喂食器，然后可以把你的信息给可能制造床垫的人，然后可以把你的信息给某个人，
who makes tires, and then who knows where your information is going. And all of a sudden, a third party that you don't even know has your information. Wow. It was fascinating. So there's a setting on your phone and on your computer where you can turn off that tracking. Yeah. So I went in and I did that.
制造轮胎的人，然后谁知道你的信息会去哪里。突然之间，一个你甚至不知道的第三方拥有了你的信息。哇。这太迷人了。所以你的手机和电脑上有一个设置，你可以关闭那个跟踪。是的。所以我进去做了那个。
Oh, well, you teach me how to do that when we get done doing this podcast. Yeah. Well, I've bought a ton of stuff from ads. Instagram. You're a big shopper, like an ad will pop up and you're like, I got a dress on Instagram today. I've bought shoes. I bought that earwax cleaner.
哦，好吧，等我们做完这个播客，你教我怎么做。好的。好吧，我从广告里买了很多东西。Instagram。你是个大购物狂，比如一个广告弹出来，你就想，我今天在Instagram上买了一件裙子。我买过鞋子。我买了那个耳垢清洁器。
I know. It didn't work. I know. Don't buy it, everybody. But I did buy that countertop composter. And you love it. I love it. I got in on that early.
我知道。它没用。我知道。大家别买。但我确实买了那个台面堆肥机。而且你很喜欢它。我喜欢它。我早早就买了。
I watched that ad before they were even available and I was one of the people who bought it when it was like at a discount because you were helping them as part of their startup. I waited seven months for that thing. Well, you were a lead and it worked. It worked. I have a thing that keeps popping up in my Instagram, you guys, and I took a screen grab because I told Josh I want it for my birthday. It's a little tiny camera that goes in your bird feeder.
我在它还没上市之前就看了那个广告，我是那些在它打折时购买的人之一，因为你作为他们创业的一部分在帮助他们。我为那个东西等了七个月。好吧，你是一个线索，而且它奏效了。它奏效了。我有一件东西一直在我的Instagram上弹出，伙计们，我截了图，因为我告诉乔什我生日想要它。那是一个放在鸟喂食器里的小型摄像头。
I sent that to you. Yes. Yeah. I want it. Yeah. And then you can like learn all about your birds and you can watch your birds. I saw that in an ad and I sent it to you. I know.
我发给你了。是的。是的。我想要它。是的。然后你可以了解所有关于你的鸟类的知识，你可以观察你的鸟类。我在广告里看到了，我发给你了。我知道。
Well, anyway, these leads from Saber are businesses that have been predetermined to want new printers, which should make it way easier than just making cold calls. You know, I worked as a telemarketer, Angela, for the St. Louis Post-Dispatch. And you had to make cold calls? I had to make cold calls, but I had leads. They were people who had expressed an interest in having a subscription to the paper. Or they were people who got the Sunday paper and I was calling them to see if they wanted to get it every day.
好吧，总之，这些来自赛博公司的线索是预先确定想要新打印机的企业，这应该比仅仅进行冷拨电话要容易得多。你知道，我曾经做过电话推销员，安吉拉，为《圣路易斯邮报》工作。你必须进行冷拨电话？我必须进行冷拨电话，但我有线索。他们是那些表示有兴趣订阅报纸的人。或者他们是收到周日版报纸的人，我打电话给他们看他们是否想每天都收到。
You would have called me because I get the Sunday paper and someone reached out to me and were like, would you like to also get the Tuesday to support the paper? Exactly. That's what I did. I said, okay, fine. So now I get it on Tuesday and Sunday. Really? Yeah.
你会打给我，因为我收到周日版报纸，有人联系我，问我是否也想收到周二版的来支持报纸？正是如此。我就是这么做的。我说，好吧，没问题。所以现在我在周二和周日都能收到。真的吗？是的。
Hey. I was a lead. Well, you know what? You helped that person bump up their sales record, too, so got persons happy. Good. So we got it, right? We know what leads are. I think we all got it.
嘿。我是一个线索。好吧，你知道吗？你也帮助那个人提高了他们的销售记录，所以那个人很高兴。很好。所以我们明白了，对吧？我们知道什么是线索了。我想我们都明白了。
Good. Fast fact number two. This was a fan mail flurry. We got a lot of mail, including from Soul C in Berkeley, California, Janine R from Mackenzie River Valley, Oregon, and Rala B from Toronto, Canada. They would all like to know what's up with the dump. They would like a location breakdown on the dump because they said the dumpster really looks like it was green screened.
很好。第二个速记事实。这是一次粉丝邮件大爆发。我们收到了很多邮件，包括来自加利福尼亚州伯克利的Soul C，俄勒冈州麦肯齐河谷的Janine R，以及加拿大安大略省多伦多的Rala B。他们都想知道垃圾场是怎么回事。他们想要一个关于垃圾场的地点剖析，因为他们说垃圾箱看起来真的很像绿幕。
How much of it is real? How large was this set? And how did they get all the garbage that Dwight and Michael threw at each other? You are right. It was a green screen. Faky dump. Faky dump. That sounds wrong.
有多少是真的？这个布景有多大？他们是怎么弄到德怀特和迈克尔互相扔的所有垃圾的？你是对的。那是绿幕。假垃圾场。假垃圾场。这听起来不对。
I like that. Faky dump. We built our version of the Scranton dump on our warehouse stage. In front of a massive green screen, Randy told me it's called a cyclorama. It actually curved around the entire periphery of the interior of our stage, too. Prior to shooting, we actually did an enormous amount of research about what the actual landfill in Scranton, Pennsylvania looked like. I believe it.
我喜欢这个。假垃圾场。我们在我们的仓库舞台上建造了我们版本的斯克兰顿垃圾场。在一个巨大的绿幕前，兰迪告诉我这叫天幕。它实际上也围绕着我们舞台内部的整个周边弯曲。在拍摄之前，我们实际上对宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿真正的垃圾填埋场的样子做了大量的研究。我相信。
Remember Mary Potis from the Scranton Chamber of Commerce? Of course. She sent pictures of the Scranton dump. Mary, you're the best. She's amazing. She started by taking a picture of a patch on a firefighters uniform and now she's taking pictures of a dump. She had no idea what she was signing up for.
还记得斯克兰顿商会的玛丽·波蒂斯吗？当然。她寄来了斯克兰顿垃圾场的照片。玛丽，你是最棒的。她太棒了。她从给消防员制服上的补丁拍照开始，现在她在给垃圾场拍照。她根本不知道自己签了什么。
She really didn't. So Michael Gallenberg was in charge of designing the dump, but the making of all the fake trash that Dwight and Michael throw at one another that fell under the jurisdiction of Steve Rothstein, our set decorator. Randy told us that he met with a local recycling firm and purchased literally hundreds of bales of sanitized recycled waste. It was mostly plastic corrugated cardboard and paper, but he added a little bit of household trash.
她真的不知道。所以迈克尔·加伦伯格负责设计垃圾场，但德怀特和迈克尔互相扔的所有假垃圾的制作归我们的布景装饰师史蒂夫·罗斯斯坦管辖。兰迪告诉我们，他会见了一家当地的回收公司，购买了数百包经过消毒的回收废物。主要是塑料瓦楞纸板和纸，但他加了一点点家庭垃圾。
He also threw in items that they could throw at each other like the big cable spool, the big sink, a tennis racket. He found the big bathtub, the purple beanbag chair, all that stuff. They took our visual effects company Stargate Studios International to a local landfill in Eagle Rock, California, and they shot a bunch of video. And that's what's playing on the green screen. They got the bulldozers and that flock of birds that flies through. I thought that was a nice touch.
他还扔进了一些他们可以互相扔的东西，比如大电缆轴、大水槽、网球拍。他找到了大浴缸、紫色豆袋椅，所有这些东西。他们带着我们的视觉特效公司Stargate Studios International去了加利福尼亚州鹰岩的一个当地垃圾填埋场，他们拍摄了很多视频。这就是在绿幕上播放的内容。他们得到了推土机和那群飞过的鸟。我觉得那是一个很好的点缀。
They took all those videos. That went on the green screen. The total budget from Stargate to create that landfill behind our piles of trash was $52,000. Wow. Yeah. And that is how you get a fakey dump. Fakey dump? That's pricy.
他们拍摄了所有那些视频。那放到了绿幕上。Stargate为在我们的垃圾堆后面创造那个垃圾填埋场的总预算是52,000美元。哇。是的。这就是你如何得到一个假垃圾场。假垃圾场？那很贵。
Yeah. Not cheap. Well, finally, fast fact number three. I mentioned earlier that this episode was both written and directed by Brent Forrester. You know we love Brent. He's always so awesome. He's the best. Well, I reached out to him to see if he wanted to send in any audio clips for this because
是的。不便宜。好吧，最后，第三个速记事实。我之前提到过这一集是由布伦特·福雷斯特编剧并执导的。你知道我们爱布伦特。他总是那么棒。他是最好的。好吧，我联系了他，看他是否想为这个节目发送任何音频片段，因为
he always is so generous with the audio. Here's what he wrote back. He said, quote, I have been dreading new leads. Oh, no, Brent. Dredding it. He said, the acting is great. Of course, you guys never waver, but the script got so mangled. He said he was also shooting a pilot for Ron Howard while we were doing this episode, crazy.
他总是对音频非常慷慨。这是他回信的内容。他说，引用，我一直很害怕《新线索》。哦，不，布伦特。害怕它。他说，表演很棒。当然，你们从不动摇，但剧本被改得面目全非。他说他在我们拍摄这一集时还在为朗·霍华德拍一部试播集，太疯狂了。
He said he just didn't feel like it turned out how he wanted. And then he said, oh my god, those special effects, they are just hilariously bad. But he did still send in some audio clips. Here's what he had to say about this episode. Hi, I'm Brent Forrester, the writer and director of New Leads. There are two big problems with this episode, the writing and the directing. The story has a fundamental flaw in it, and there's a fundamental lesson in it for all you writers.
他说他只是觉得结果不像他想要的那样。然后他说，天哪，那些特效，简直是滑稽地糟糕。但他确实还是发来了一些音频片段。这是他关于这一集的看法。嗨，我是《新线索》的编剧兼导演布伦特·福雷斯特。这一集有两个大问题，编剧和导演。故事有一个根本性的缺陷，对于你们所有编剧来说，这里有一个根本性的教训。
The secret of storytelling in the half hour medium is to center the story around two characters in conflict. Let that conflict build to a crisis and then resolve. That's the right story for half hour TV. Look at New Leads. Who are the two characters in conflict? It's Michael and who? Well, it's the whole office.
半小时媒介中讲故事的秘诀是让故事围绕两个冲突的角色展开。让那种冲突升级为危机，然后解决。那是半小时电视节目的正确故事。看看《新线索》。哪两个角色在冲突？是迈克尔和谁？好吧，是整个办公室。
It's kind of vague. It doesn't center in on Michael versus Dwight until the third act, and by then it's too late. It's so obvious to me now, but I totally miss it at the time because I was so focused on doing a terrible job of directing this episode. Brent, stop it. I absolutely enjoyed this episode. You're being way too critical of yourself.
这有点模糊。直到第三幕它才集中在迈克尔对德怀特上，到那时已经太晚了。现在对我来说太明显了，但我当时完全错过了，因为我太专注于导演这一集做得太糟糕了。布伦特，别这样。我非常喜欢这一集。你对自己太苛刻了。
Just stop. Let that go. Can you tell that he teaches screenwriting comedy? Yes. Because he always breaks it down from that intellectual level, which I love. I always love hearing that perspective. I know. He's so smart.
停下。放手吧。你能看出他教编剧喜剧吗？是的。因为他总是从那个知识层面剖析它，我喜欢这一点。我总是喜欢听到那个视角。我知道。他太聪明了。
Brent sent in one more audio clip. We'll play it later because he does have a favorite scene from this episode. Oh, good. Well, listen, before we go to break, I have a fun little detail about this episode. What? If you do a re-watch of this episode, look for the people wearing the little Bluetooth headphones and typing on their phones during meetings. There was a lot of old tech.
布伦特又发来了一个音频片段。我们稍后会播放它，因为他确实有这一集中最喜欢的场景。哦，太好了。好吧，听着，在我们休息之前，关于这一集我有一个有趣的小细节。什么？如果你重温这一集，留意那些在会议期间戴着小蓝牙耳机并在手机上打字的人。有很多旧技术。
Yeah. These little headphones and this bits of business, these were things that were sprinkled into the show to kind of amplify the status of the sales team. We did not normally see these. It's kind of exclusive to this episode, and I had a good time spotting them. I'm going to point them out. Good. No one wears a headset like Phyllis.
是的。这些小耳机和这些业务片段，这些是穿插在节目中以某种方式放大销售团队地位的东西。我们通常看不到这些。这在这一集中是独有的，我很高兴能发现它们。我会指出来。好的。没有人像菲利斯那样戴耳机。
I know. All right. Well, we'll take a break and we'll be back with a cold open that I'm titling My Bad. We are back, and let's get into this cold open, which I'm calling My Bad. You guys, many of you reached out and reminded us that this Johnny Depp cold open that we talked about in double date. I had said I found this deleted scene that was going to be a cold open for that episode, and lady, this is a direct quote of us from the double date podcast.
我知道。好吧，我们会休息一下，然后回来，带上我称之为“我的错”的冷开场。我们回来了，让我们进入这个冷开场，我称之为“我的错”。伙计们，你们很多人联系我们并提醒我们，我们在《双重约会》中谈到的那个约翰尼·德普的冷开场。我说我找到了这个被删减的场景，它本来是那一集的冷开场，女士，这是我们从《双重约会》播客中直接引用的。
You're going to quote us. I'm quoting us. I say it's a really funny scene, and we shot it. It also includes Michael's impression of Jack Sparrow. That exists somewhere. It does exist somewhere. It's called New Leads. You responded, and you said, you know, this is crazy.
你要引用我们。我正在引用我们。我说这是一个非常有趣的场景，我们拍了它。它还包括迈克尔对杰克船长的模仿。那存在于某个地方。它确实存在于某个地方。它叫《新线索》。你回应了，你说，你知道，这太疯狂了。
This is unlocking a memory for me. When we read that at the table read, we all thought it was so funny, amazing. You guys, clearly, we are rewatching this for the first time in a very long time. In real time. As it turns out, and many of you knew this and wrote in, that cold open was salvaged. It was repurposed for this episode, New Leads. And thank you for all of you who pointed that out. I'm going to try to redeem us here for a moment, Jenna.
这正在为我解锁一段记忆。当我们读到那个剧本围读时，我们都觉得它太有趣了，太棒了。伙计们，显然，我们这是在很长一段时间以来第一次重温它。实时地。事实证明，你们很多人都知道这一点并写信进来，那个冷开场被挽救了。它被重新用于这一集，《新线索》。感谢所有指出这一点的人。我打算在这里为我们挽回一点面子，珍娜。
I would like to share with you guys what the original cold open was for New Leads. Oh, what was it? I went to the table read, the original cold open for this was where everyone is doing push-ups, and Michael says, if you can reach 15 push-ups, you get to go home early and Stanley wins. That is now going to be the cold open of happy hour. Coming up next week. Coming up next week.
我想和你们分享一下《新线索》最初的冷开场是什么。哦，那是什么？我去参加了剧本围读，这个最初的冷开场是每个人都在做俯卧撑，迈克尔说，如果你能做到15个俯卧撑，你就可以早点回家，斯坦利赢了。那现在将成为《欢乐时光》的冷开场。下周播出。下周播出。
There you go. That ends my segment called My Bad. Well, what should be very clear to everyone was that we would move around these cold opens. Yes. That was the point of them, that they stood alone, that they didn't have to lead any particular episode, they were one little joke in and of themselves, and they were moved often.
就是这样。这结束了我的名为“我的错”的片段。好吧，对每个人来说应该非常清楚的是，我们会移动这些冷开场。是的。这就是它们的意义，它们是独立的，它们不必引导任何特定的剧集，它们本身就是一个小笑话，而且它们经常被移动。
Yeah, they got scooched. Well, we had a great fan catch from Maddie B. in North Adams, Massachusetts. She noticed that Jim is wearing his sport coat in this cold open with Michael. She said now, he only wore that sport coat when he was a co-manager. When he returns to sales, he goes back to his simple shirt and tie and rolled up sleeves. She said, I think this cold open was filmed during one of the episodes when Jim was the manager. Yes, Maddie, you are correct.
是的，它们被挪动了。好吧，我们从马萨诸塞州北亚当斯的麦迪B那里得到了一个很棒的粉丝发现。她注意到吉姆在这个与迈克尔的冷开场中穿着他的运动外套。她说现在，他只有在担任联合经理时才穿那件运动外套。当他回到销售岗位时，他又穿回了他简单的衬衫和领带，卷起袖子。她说，我想这个冷开场是在吉姆担任经理的其中一集拍摄的。是的，麦迪，你是对的。
This was shot five months before this episode when Jim was still a co-manager during double date. Great catch, Maddie. We also had a fan catch from Catlin C. in Iowa who says, old tech alert. In the cold open, when Michael shows Jim a picture of Johnny Depp that he took at his condo, it is a physical photo that he took with a camera and had to get developed. Catlin says it cracks me up that he printed out the pictures. Yeah.
这是在这一集五个月前拍摄的，当时吉姆还是《双重约会》期间的联合经理。伟大的发现，麦迪。我们还收到了来自爱荷华州凯特琳C的粉丝发现，她说，旧技术警报。在冷开场中，当迈克尔向吉姆展示他在公寓里拍的约翰尼·德普的照片时，那是一张他用相机拍并必须冲洗出来的实体照片。凯特琳说，他把照片打印出来让我笑死了。是的。
Yes, today he would just show his phone. Yeah, this happened a lot for Jen and I when we were working on our book because we would bring ye oldie cameras to the set and we'd go to the mall to the little photo kiosk. So we'd bring in our pictures and we found so many just like that. Well I have some more old tech alerts for this episode. I love an old tech alert. I know you do. Well, this episode actually starts in the conference room.
是的，今天他只会展示他的手机。是的，这在珍和我在为我们的书工作时经常发生，因为我们会带老式相机去片场，我们会去商场的那个小照片亭。所以我们会带进我们的照片，我们发现了这么多像那样的照片。好吧，我这一集还有更多的旧技术警报。我喜欢旧技术警报。我知道你喜欢。好吧，这一集实际上是从会议室开始的。
Michael has called a meeting. He starts by telling everyone that the lost and found is lost. This really cracked me up. And I loved Creed's face. I loved his giant circle black framed glasses. Who lost those? What is Jackie Kennedy here? Who's wearing those?
迈克尔召集了一个会议。他首先告诉大家失物招领处丢了。这真的让我笑死了。我喜欢克里德的脸。我喜欢他那副巨大的黑色圆框眼镜。谁丢了那些？杰基·肯尼迪在这里吗？谁戴着那些？
I don't know. Stanley and Dwight, they just want to talk about sales. That's it. They don't want any of this other nonsense. And what they want to know is there any word on the new leads from corporate? Saber spent $50,000 on these leads and they haven't gotten them yet. And they're not going to sit around in this conference room. They're busy.
我不知道。斯坦利和德怀特，他们只想谈论销售。就是这样。他们不想听任何其他废话。他们想知道的是，公司关于新线索有什么消息吗？赛博公司在这些线索上花了5万美元，但他们还没拿到。他们不会坐在这个会议室里干等。他们很忙。
They're real busy. Did you notice the dry erase board? I did. But I didn't zoom in on it. Did you? Oh, you know I did. And I got some dry erase board stats for you. All right.
他们真的很忙。你注意到白板了吗？我注意到了。但我没有放大看。你放大了吗？哦，你知道我放大了。我为你准备了一些白板统计数据。好的。
They don't quite match up with the storyline. Really? Dwight is not in the lead. So I zoomed in and I was able to see all of the paper sales. I couldn't see the printer sales, but the paper sales, here's the stats. Andy has sold 18. Whatever that means. Dwight has sold 21.
它们与故事情节不太吻合。真的吗？德怀特不在领先位置。所以我放大了，我能够看到所有的纸张销售。我看不见打印机销售，但纸张销售，这是统计数据。安迪卖了18个。不管那意味着什么。德怀特卖了21个。
Pam has sold 19. Pam has sold 2. Oh boy. Phyllis has sold 25 and Stanley has sold 16. So Phyllis is in the lead. Phyllis is in the lead according to the dry erase board. According to the paper sales of the dry erase board. Exactly.
帕姆卖了19个。帕姆卖了2个。哦，天哪。菲利斯卖了25个，斯坦利卖了16个。所以菲利斯领先。根据白板，菲利斯领先。根据白板上的纸张销售。正是如此。
Printers might be another story. Maybe Dwight is selling a lot of printers. Yeah, they were in green and they were way just tiny in the margin there and I couldn't see them. Well, at two minutes and six seconds Phyllis has her Bluetooth and Jim is texting on his blackberry. So you've got some busy sales business going on. Lots of business.
打印机可能是另一回事。也许德怀特卖了很多打印机。是的，它们是绿色的，它们就在边缘那里，非常小，我看不见。好吧，在两分零六秒，菲利斯戴着她的蓝牙耳机，吉姆正在他的黑莓手机上发短信。所以你有一些忙碌的销售业务正在进行。很多业务。
We also had a fan question from Alexis J and Santa Barbara, California and KDH from Ohio. In the conference room scene, Michael mentions Pet Day. I know, I heard that, I was like ding, ding, ding, oh. Yes, they said is this a reference based on the unreleased episode or script about Pet Day? We have talked about this before, there was an unproduced script called Pet Day and we always said maybe that's how we all come back together. We do this lost episode Pet Day.
我们还收到了来自加利福尼亚州圣巴巴拉的亚历克西斯J和来自俄亥俄州的KDH的粉丝提问。在会议室场景中，迈克尔提到了宠物日。我知道，我听到了，我就像叮，叮，叮，哦。是的，他们说这是基于未发布的剧集或关于宠物日的剧本的参考吗？我们之前谈过这个，有一个未制作的剧本叫《宠物日》，我们总是说也许这就是我们所有人重新聚在一起的方式。我们制作这个丢失的剧集《宠物日》。
As if no time has passed, even though we all look much older. Right. That would be so crazy. By the way, did you know that there is a national take your dog to work day? Oh, I would love that. It is the Monday after Father's Day this year on June 24th. What? I feel like I remember one year before the pandemic, we came into Ear Wolf and everyone's
好像时间没有流逝一样，尽管我们看起来都老了很多。对。那会太疯狂了。顺便说一句，你知道有一个全国带狗上班日吗？哦，我会喜欢那个的。今年是在父亲节后的星期一，6月24日。什么？我觉得我记得疫情前的一年，我们来到Ear Wolf，每个人的
dogs were here. There was a dog that always hung out here by front reception. But Sam, has there been like a bring your dog to Ear Wolf day? No, there hasn't. It, it bums me out very much. Well June 24th is coming up, maybe we need to get on it. I would really like that. All right.
狗都在这里。有一只狗总是待在前台接待处。但是萨姆，有没有像带你的狗来Ear Wolf日？不，没有。这让我非常沮丧。好吧，6月24日快到了，也许我们需要开始行动了。我真的会喜欢那个。好的。
June 24th is a Friday, put it on your calendar. Listen, Biscuit is not good with other people. She doesn't like anyone or anything, except for me. I look forward to Biscuit coming in for Buster, though, I could just hide in my sweatshirt. No one would ever see him. Well, if you need someone to herd the other animals, Maggie can do that for you. Yeah. Yeah.
6月24日是星期五，把它记在你的日历上。听着，比斯吉特对其他人不太好。她不喜欢任何人或任何东西，除了我。不过，我期待比斯吉特来找巴斯特，我可以躲在我的运动衫里。没人会看见他。好吧，如果你需要有人来放牧其他动物，玛吉可以为你做那个。是的。是的。
She'll keep things in order. There would have been a joint Stanley Phyllis talking head here. It's in deleted scenes and we learn a little bit of Stanley's history. Let's hear it. I've been here a long time, 31 years, and for the first time things have been done right. And all that time. I just think our new bosses realize what I've been thinking all along.
她会保持秩序。这里本来有一个联合斯坦利和菲利斯的谈话头。它在被删减的场景里，我们了解了一点斯坦利的背景。让我们听听。我在这里待了很长时间，31年了，这是第一次事情做得对。在所有那段时间里。我只是认为我们的新老板意识到了我一直以来的想法。
The sales business is the whole business. It's the whole thing. Okay. This is why Stanley and Phyllis get along. Yeah. I love their dynamic. I do too. And we found out that Stanley has worked there for 31 years.
销售业务就是整个业务。就是全部。好的。这就是为什么斯坦利和菲利斯相处得来。是的。我喜欢他们的动态。我也喜欢。我们发现斯坦利在那里工作了31年。
Any wonder he is so over the BS. Wow. So true. Gosh. Well, Michael has a talking head where he explains that things are changing around here. And during this talking head, we see the sales staff getting all their swag. I mean, they are getting just packages of stuff, a robe, fancy coffee containers. A travel bag, like a jacket.
难怪他那么厌倦废话。哇。太真实了。天哪。好吧，迈克尔有一个谈话头，他解释说这里的事情正在改变。在这个谈话头期间，我们看到销售人员得到了他们所有的赠品。我的意思是，他们得到的只是成包的东西，长袍，精致的咖啡容器。旅行包，像夹克。
Yeah. This was all courtesy of our graphics designer, Henry Sane, and made by Phil Shea. Do I just going to go up to Michael and say, have you gotten the leads? Do you need to let me know when you get the leads? Let's him know how to contact him. This cracks me up. Can we hear it? You got any news on leads?
是的。这一切都要归功于我们的图形设计师亨利·塞恩，并由菲尔·谢制作。德怀特要走到迈克尔面前说，你拿到线索了吗？你需要在我拿到线索时通知我吗？让他知道如何联系他。这让我笑死了。我们可以听听吗？你有关于线索的消息吗？
Okay. I tell you what. I'm going out on a very important sales call. If you get any news about the leads, you try me. All of my numbers. All six of my numbers. Okay? Including the car phone.
好的。我告诉你。我要去进行一个非常重要的销售电话。如果你得到任何关于线索的消息，你联系我。我所有的号码。我所有的六个号码。好的？包括车载电话。
All right. Dwight out. Dwight out. You know what I wrote down in my document? What are his six phone numbers? Does he have like burner phones? He says, and the car phone. Where is Michael calling him?
好的。德怀特出局。德怀特出局。你知道我在我的文档里写了什么吗？他的六个电话号码是什么？他有像一次性手机吗？他说，还有车载电话。迈克尔在哪里打给他？
I don't know. But that tells me he has seven phone numbers. If he has six plus the car phone, right? Is Michael calling him at home? What are these numbers? I don't know. But I wish someone would call them all at the same time. Why has Jim not thought of that?
我不知道。但这告诉我他有七个电话号码。如果他有六个加上车载电话，对吧？迈克尔是在家里打给他吗？这些号码是什么？我不知道。但我希望有人能同时打给他们所有人。为什么吉姆没想过那个？
I know. That's a good Jim prank. In Dwight's talking head, he says salesman is king at three minutes, 21 seconds. He's also wearing his Bluetooth headset. Hey. Pointing it out. You thought I wouldn't, but I am. No.
我知道。那是一个很好的吉姆恶作剧。在德怀特的谈话头中，他说销售员是国王，在三分21秒。他还戴着他的蓝牙耳机。嘿。指出来。你以为我不会，但我会。不。
Please don't stop. Dwight had an alternate talking head, and here it is. It's how he's going to spend his commission money. I love these new rules. I no longer have to deal with paperwork. And because of this new pay structure, there is literally no limit to the amount of money I can make. It is possible.
请不要停。德怀特有一个替代的谈话头，这是它。他打算怎么花他的佣金。我喜欢这些新规则。我不再需要处理文书工作了。而且因为这个新的薪酬结构，我能赚的钱确实没有上限。这是可能的。
Stay with me here. It is possible I can make over $100,000 this year. I can only be able to put in that pool, Mos and I have been dreaming of, to drown pigs you mainly. Oh my gosh. That took a turn. That took a turn. Wait.
跟我来。这是可能的，我今年能赚超过10万美元。我只能把那个池子放进去，莫斯和我一直梦想着，淹死猪你主要是。天哪。那发生了一个转折。那发生了一个转折。等等。
And he also said, and to cross train. Oh my gosh. I know. I couldn't wait. I couldn't wait to see your face because I did the same thing. I was like, oh, they want a swimming pool. Oh my God. Oh my.
他还说，还有去交叉训练。天哪。我知道。我等不及了。我等不及要看你的脸了，因为我做了同样的事情。我就像，哦，他们想要一个游泳池。天哪。哦，我的。
Coming up, we have some sass, some major sass. Angela has emailed Phyllis four times asking her to come over to her desk. Four times. Phyllis says, if I don't have time to read your emails, I don't have time to walk over to your desk. Yeah. Phyllis sass. I mean, she is the busiest beaver.
接下来，我们有一些时髦，一些主要的时髦。安吉拉给菲利斯发了四次邮件，要求她到她的办公桌前。四次。菲利斯说，如果我没时间读你的邮件，我就没时间走到你的办公桌前。是的。菲利斯时髦。我的意思是，她是最大的忙碌海狸。
This is true. Well, this scene was much longer. I yelled at the TV when I was watching it in deleted scenes because Andy is going to like Angela to a type of bird. You have to hear it. Here is your expense report, which you signed, but you did not fill out. I was busy. That's the reason.
这是真的。好吧，这个场景长得多。我在看被删减的场景时对电视大喊大叫，因为安迪要把安吉拉比作一种鸟。你必须听听。这是你的费用报告，你签了名，但你没有填写。我很忙。这就是原因。
We're all busy. Hey, Ange, do you mind if I handle this? If a company does not move forward, it will die like a shark. If it stays still, it gets no oxygen. If we stay still, we get no sales and the money is our oxygen. So it's really a pretty good metaphor if you think about it. For God's sakes. No, seriously, you're trying to hover like a bird and birds can't do that unless you're
我们都很忙。嘿，安吉，你介意我处理这个吗？如果一家公司不前进，它就会像鲨鱼一样死亡。如果它保持静止，它就得不到氧气。如果我们保持静止，我们就得不到销售，钱就是我们的氧气。所以如果你仔细想想，这真的是一个很好的隐喻。看在上帝的份上。不，说真的，你试图像鸟一样盘旋，而鸟做不到，除非你是
a hummingbird. A hummingbird. Like a hummingbird. You guys, I'm such a dork, I was like, all of my world's colliding, the office and hummingbirds. I want to point out also that Ed Helms, who calls me Ange in real life, who has called me Ange as Andy once before. No one else at Dunder Mifflin calls me Ange. Once again, I feel like he slipped more into Ed than Andy and he called me Ange.
一只蜂鸟。一只蜂鸟。像一只蜂鸟。伙计们，我真是个书呆子，我就像，我所有的世界都在碰撞，《办公室》和蜂鸟。我还想指出，在现实生活中叫我安吉的埃德·赫尔姆斯，他曾经作为安迪叫过我一次安吉。邓德·米夫林没有其他人叫我安吉。再一次，我觉得他更多地滑向了埃德而不是安迪，他叫我安吉。
Wow. That just made me happy. So I wanted to share it. Well, speaking of Andy at four minutes and 17 seconds, he's got his Bluetooth headphone in his ear. He does and he needs a pencil really bad. Yeah. He asked Daryl if he can just have the pencil that Daryl is using.
哇。那让我很高兴。所以我想要分享它。好吧，说到安迪，在四分17秒，他耳朵里戴着蓝牙耳机。他戴着，而且他非常需要一支铅笔。是的。他问达里尔他是否可以只拿达里尔正在用的那支铅笔。
Daryl was like, oh no, this was hilarious to me. So funny. We got a fan question from Gretchen S. in Holland. When Andy is wrestling Daryl for a pencil, how much of that was scripted because that scene was great. You know what? None of that was in the script. When they wrestle and go to the ground?
达里尔就像，哦不，这对我来说太搞笑了。太有趣了。我们收到了来自荷兰格雷琴S的粉丝提问。当安迪为了铅笔和达里尔摔跤时，有多少是按剧本演的，因为那个场景太棒了。你知道吗？剧本里根本没有那个。当他们摔跤并倒地时？
Yeah. In the script, it just says Andy makes the gimme gesture as the camera pushes in on Daryl in disbelief and then it ended. So all of him like trying to take it from his hand and then them falling. And I think you can see at the end of that scene, you can see Craig. I see him breaking. I also see him breaking. I see him starting to laugh.
是的。在剧本里，它只是说安迪做了给我的手势，摄像机推向难以置信的达里尔，然后它就结束了。所以他试图从他手里拿走，然后他们倒下。而且我想你可以在那个场景结束时看到，你可以看到克雷格。我看到他破功了。我也看到他破功了。我看到他开始笑。
And then he tries to grab Ed. So he doesn't bonk his head and fall. Yeah. I think he has to kind of do a bit of a crotch grab there and they cut away at the very last minute if you check it out. I would like to point out at four minutes, 22 seconds behind Daryl on the wall is a sign that says nobody talks, everybody walks. A lot of people wanted this sign and I saw on the internet that NBC actually sold it in
然后他试图抓住埃德。所以他不会撞到头并倒下。是的。我想他必须在那里做一点胯部抓取，如果你检查一下，他们在最后一分钟切走了。我想指出在四分22秒，达里尔身后的墙上有一个标志，上面写着没人说话，每个人都走。很多人想要这个标志，我在互联网上看到NBC实际上把它卖了
an auction they had of all the set pieces from the show. Wow. So somebody bought it. Someone has it. Wait a second. Here's what I don't understand. Remember when they said I couldn't have my watercolor because they had to log it and put it in a warehouse in case we ever revived the show or something?
在他们举行的一场拍卖会上，拍卖了节目中所有的布景。哇。所以有人买了它。有人拥有它。等一下。这是我不明白的地方。还记得他们说我不能要我的水彩画，因为他们必须记录它并把它放在仓库里，以防我们复活这个节目或什么的吗？
I think they just wanted to sell everything. I mean, what happens if we ever want to revive the show? I mean, they've sold everything. They sold our clothes. I know. I know. What happens? I don't know.
我想他们只是想卖掉一切。我的意思是，如果我们复活这个节目会发生什么？我的意思是，他们卖掉了一切。他们卖掉了我们的衣服。我知道。我知道。会发生什么？我不知道。
Maybe that's why we're not reviving it because it would cost too much to go get the stuff back. There was like a fire sale of all the set pieces. There really was. Yeah. So I found that interesting that that particular sign was sold and someone has it. We also had a fan catch from Eleanor in France for this scene. Bonjour.
也许这就是为什么我们不复活它，因为去把东西拿回来太贵了。有一场所有布景的清仓大甩卖。真的有。是的。所以我发现那个特定的标志被卖掉而且有人拥有它很有趣。我们还收到了来自法国埃莉诺的粉丝发现，关于这个场景。你好。
Bonjour. Well, Eleanor said at around four minutes, 15 seconds, when Andy is walking past Daryl's office, I swear he says, Eddie, nice. But then later on he says, hang on, Teddy. So did he say the wrong name on one of those? Was this supposed to happen? Eleanor, I went to the script. There were no names in the script.
你好。好吧，埃莉诺说在大约四分15秒，当安迪走过达里尔的办公室时，我发誓他说，埃迪，不错。但后来他说，坚持住，泰迪。所以他是在其中一个说错了名字吗？这本来应该发生吗？埃莉诺，我看了剧本。剧本里没有名字。
I think this was Ed just kind of riffing at the top of this scene. I pulled an audio clip because I think Eleanor is right. Let's listen to it. Oh, is this going to be like, is the dress blue or black? Yeah. Okay. So we're listening for... We're listening for Eddie first and then Teddy.
我想这是埃德在这一场景开始时即兴发挥。我拉了一个音频片段，因为我认为埃莉诺是对的。让我们听听。哦，这会像，裙子是蓝色还是黑色吗？是的。好的。所以我们正在听……我们先听埃迪，然后是泰迪。
Got it. Eddie, nice. Let me just... Let me write that down real quick. Pencil. Give me a pencil. Hang on, Teddy. Right?
明白了。埃迪，不错。让我……让我快速写下来。铅笔。给我一支铅笔。坚持住，泰迪。对吧？
He totally says Eddie and then Teddy. I think so too. Yeah. Good catch, Eleanor. Yeah. Sable. Magnifique. That is all the French I know, unless I'm at a fruit stand and it comes pouring out
他完全说了埃迪，然后是泰迪。我也这么认为。是的。伟大的发现，埃莉诺。是的。赛博。太美了。这就是我知道的所有法语，除非我在水果摊，它会喷涌而出
of me. Right. Daryl finds Michael in the kitchen. Michael's really sad because his honey and jelly sandwich has been smushed and Daryl says, you know what? It was the sales team. It was. He didn't have to see him to know it.
从我身上。对。达里尔在厨房里找到了迈克尔。迈克尔真的很伤心，因为他的蜂蜜和果冻三明治被压扁了，达里尔说，你知道吗？是销售团队。确实是。他不需要看到他就能知道。
They're out of control and Michael needs to get back on top of this. That's what she said. Yeah. Yeah. That's what she said was not in the script. What? After get back on top? Yes.
他们失控了，迈克尔需要重新掌握局面。这就是她说的。是的。是的。这就是她说的，不在剧本里。什么？在重新掌握局面之后？是的。
Can you believe that Brent wrote the line, you need to get back on top, and he did not follow that with a scripted. That's what she said. Oh, man. Brent, you were distracted. Yeah. You were. This is the proof.
你能相信布伦特写了那句，你需要重新掌握局面，而他没有跟上一句剧本里的“这就是她说的”吗？哦，伙计。布伦特，你分心了。是的。你是。这是证据。
This is all the proof you need. You know, also in the script, there wasn't just one sandwich. Michael reveals that there were eight sandwiches and that he brings them all to work at the same time and that they were all smashed. Just so you know, I thought that was so strange quirk that Michael brings, like, all of his sandwiches for the week. For the whole week. Yeah.
这是你需要的所有证据。你知道，在剧本里，也不止一个三明治。迈克尔透露有八个三明治，他把它们全部带到工作地点，而且它们都被压扁了。只是让你知道，我认为迈克尔带，比如，他一周所有的三明治是一个非常奇怪的怪癖。为了整个星期。是的。
How did they all get smashed? I don't know. I'm going to say creed. I don't know. Were they just like muscling all the food in the refrigerator, just like pounding it to the sides? Somebody. Michael is finally going to receive the new leads, Phyllis demands that he hand them over.
它们是怎么被压扁的？我不知道。我会说是克雷德。我不知道。它们只是像把所有的食物都塞进冰箱，就像把它撞到侧面一样？某人。迈克尔终于要收到新线索了，菲利斯要求他交出来。
She calls them numb nuts. I know. I mean, that's out of line, Phyllis. But Michael says he's not going to give them the leads. And the accounting department applauds, Angela. You are applauding over there in the corner. Yeah, we've had it. Did you notice that the leads arrived by snail mail?
她叫他们笨蛋。我知道。我的意思是，那越界了，菲利斯。但迈克尔说他不会给他们线索。会计部门鼓掌，安吉拉。你在角落里鼓掌。是的，我们受够了。你注意到线索是通过平邮到达的吗？
And they're on, like, little blue cards? Yeah. That's my other old tech alert. And we had a fan question from Fiona in Melbourne, Australia, who said, wouldn't these very valuable leads have been emailed or provided digitally because putting them on index cards and only index cards seems unlikely and maybe like a forced device for this episode. Is there a sales business thing that I'm missing here? I thought deeply about this, Fiona, because I don't disagree with you.
而且它们在，比如，蓝色的小卡片上？是的。那是我的另一个旧技术警报。我们收到了来自澳大利亚墨尔本菲奥娜的粉丝提问，她说，这些非常有价值的线索难道不应该通过电子邮件发送或以数字方式提供吗，因为把它们放在索引卡上，而且只放在索引卡上似乎不太可能，也许像这一集的一个强制装置。有什么销售业务的事情是我错过的吗？我深入思考了这一点，菲奥娜，因为我不同意你的看法。
I thought about Christians later. The wolf. Oh. Yeah. Remember? Yeah. Have you ever tasted a rainbow? How could we forget?
我后来想到了基督徒。狼。哦。是的。记得吗？是的。你尝过彩虹吗？我们怎么能忘记？
Well, I thought about computer hackers. You know, maybe they don't want these going around digitally because of hackers. But here's the thing, they had to be on a computer at some point in order to print them out. Unless the company who generates the leads sends them in physical form only, I don't know. I guess in my mind, Fiona, it made sense because this company that's giving them the information, it's like giving currency.
好吧，我想到了电脑黑客。你知道，也许他们不想让这些东西因为黑客而以数字方式流传。但问题是，它们必须在某个时候在电脑上才能打印出来。除非生成线索的公司只以物理形式发送它们，我不知道。我想在我的脑海里，菲奥娜，这说得通，因为这家提供信息的公司，就像给货币一样。
It's like giving money. And they would almost probably want like a, like sign upon receipt, you know, that you received these, they're very valuable, it's $50,000. And they might not want to exchange that type of currency over the internet, especially if you think about when this episode took place. I believed that they could come by mail, like via signature. Yeah, this was in the past. I mean, remember, Michael had to print out his pictures earlier.
这就像是给钱。他们几乎肯定会想要一个，比如收到后的签名，你知道的，证明你收到了这些，它们非常值钱，有5万美元。而且他们可能不想在互联网上交换那种货币，特别是如果你考虑到这一集发生的时间。我相信它们可以通过邮件寄送，比如通过签名。是的，这是过去的事了。我的意思是，记得吗，迈克尔早些时候不得不打印出他的照片。
Yeah. People still faxed things. Yeah. I have two background catches during this scene at five minutes, 49 seconds. You can see Kate Flannery's screen. She had been playing solitaire. She's always playing solitaire. Always playing solitaire.
是的。人们当时还在用传真机。是的。在这一幕5分49秒时，我有两个背景发现。你可以看到凯特·弗兰纳里的屏幕。她一直在玩纸牌游戏。她总是玩纸牌游戏。总是玩纸牌游戏。
I mean, you know what we need is to catch her screen doing something else. I know. And Meredith has a nice callback to Kelly's American Idol party with her star party favor mug. Mm-hmm. Very nice. Listen, Gabe tells Michael, we spent a lot of money on these leads, you have to hand them out.
我的意思是，你知道我们需要的是抓到她的屏幕在做别的事情。我知道。而且梅雷迪斯对凯利的《美国偶像》派对有一个很好的呼应，她带着她的明星派对礼品杯。嗯哼。非常好。听着，盖博告诉迈克尔，我们在这些潜在客户上花了很多钱，你必须把它们分发出去。
You have to. And Michael says, you know what? I will do exactly that. Yes. Because Gabe says, you are required to hand out those leads, Michael. Mm-hmm. Well, he can hand them out. Doesn't say who he has to hand them out to.
你必须这样做。迈克尔说，你知道吗？我会完全照做。是的。因为盖博说，你必须分发那些潜在客户，迈克尔。嗯哼。好吧，他可以分发它们。没说他必须分发给谁。
Yeah. So it turns out he's going to hand them out to King Creed and King Meredith and King Angela because today we are all Kings and Queens. Mm-hmm. Everyone is delighted. I mean, not the sales staff, but everyone else is loving this turn of events. Right. But listen, lady, before we keep going, do you want to take a break?
是的。结果他打算把它们分发给克里德国王、梅雷迪斯女王和安吉拉女王，因为今天我们都是国王和王后。嗯哼。每个人都很高兴。我的意思是，不是销售人员，但其他人都在享受这一事件的转折。对。但是听着，女士，在我们继续之前，你想休息一下吗？
Yeah, let's take a break. And when we come back, I heard a little St. Louis. Ooh, from Miss Phyllis. Mm-hmm. Very good. Jim is confronting Michael. He says, Michael, no one is going to go along with this move. But you knew that.
是的，我们休息一下吧。当我们回来时，我听到了一点圣路易斯。噢，来自菲利斯小姐。嗯哼。非常好。吉姆正在质问迈克尔。他说，迈克尔，没有人会同意这个举动。但你早就知道了。
Right. Michael said, you know what? You're right. You want me to hand you the leads? Jim's like, yeah. He's like, OK, here you go. And he hands them some index cards, but they're not the leads. They're like clues.
对。迈克尔说，你知道吗？你是对的。你想让我把潜在客户交给你吗？吉姆说，是的。他说，好吧，给你。然后他递给他一些索引卡，但它们不是潜在客户。它们就像是线索。
Mm-hmm. I do love the scene with Jim and Pam on the phone, and she's like breaking down Michael's clues. Yes, because one of the clues is check in Michael's Mopi place. But Pam quickly says he means his Mopi place. Yeah. But basically, this sets off this same dynamic with all of the non-sales people. They are going to make the salespeople do crazy things to get these leads.
嗯哼。我确实很喜欢吉姆和帕姆在电话里的那一幕，她就像是在破解迈克尔的线索。是的，因为其中一个线索是检查迈克尔的“Mopi”地方。但帕姆很快说他指的是他的“Mopi”地方。是的。但基本上，这引发了所有非销售人员的同样动态。他们要让销售人员做疯狂的事情来获得这些潜在客户。
Yeah. Angela says to Phyllis, you have to do all this clerical work to get the leads. I heard a little bit of St. Louis at 8 minutes 57 seconds. Oh, really? Mm-hmm. When Angela hands her the stack of papers, Phyllis goes, what are these for? Ah! I love it.
是的。安吉拉对菲利斯说，你必须做所有这些文书工作才能获得潜在客户。我在8分57秒听到了一点圣路易斯。噢，真的吗？嗯哼。当安吉拉把那叠文件递给她时，菲利斯说，这些是干什么用的？啊！我喜欢它。
Go to 8 minutes 57 seconds. You'll hear it. Well, Angela says she has to fill out all that paperwork, and when she's done, then Phyllis can watch Angela shred it. Oh, so mean. Gosh, she's given the sass back. Angela and Phyllis, man. All right, this next scene delighted me.
去8分57秒。你会听到的。好吧，安吉拉说她必须填完所有那些文书工作，当她做完后，菲利斯就可以看安吉拉粉碎它。噢，太刻薄了。天哪，她开始反击了。安吉拉和菲利斯，天哪。好了，下一幕让我很高兴。
The Stanley, like, sitting between Kelly and Ryan arguing. And Kelly is saying that she wants to watch Keeping Up with the Kardashians, and Stanley's like, yeah, yeah, so Kelly hands him a lead for taking her side. And then I had to rewind it a couple of times to hear what Kelly was saying. I could only catch the word board at first, but what Kelly is saying is she does not want to watch Board to Death. Oh, is that Ryan's show? Yes!
斯坦利坐在凯利和瑞安中间争吵。凯利说她想看《与卡戴珊姐妹同行》，斯坦利说，是啊，是啊，所以凯利因为他站在她这边而给了他一个潜在客户。然后我不得不倒带几次来听凯利在说什么。起初我只能听清“board”这个词，但凯利说的是她不想看《凡人烦人》(Bored to Death)。噢，那是瑞安的节目吗？是的！
I looked it up. It's an HBO sitcom that starred Jason Schwartzman. Yes. Did you watch it when it was on? I remember I watched, like, the pilot episode and thought it was so funny, and I was like, oh, I'll get back to it. It had Ted Danson. Yes, yeah.
我查过了。这是一部由杰森·舒瓦兹曼主演的HBO情景喜剧。是的。它播出时你看过吗？我记得我看了试播集，觉得太搞笑了，我就想，噢，我会回头看的。里面有泰德·丹森。是的，是的。
And Zach Galifianakis, Kristen Wiig has a big guest star, Parker Posey, a lot of funny people. I found a trailer for it. Ooh. There's something I've been meaning to tell you. Oh, sh**. I hate when people say that. What?
还有扎克·加利凡纳基斯，克里斯汀·韦格是一个大客串明星，帕克·波西，很多有趣的人。我找到了它的预告片。噢。有件事我一直想告诉你。噢，该死。我讨厌人们那样说。什么？
I've been moonlighting as a private detective. I thought you'd be older. Well, I got into the business at a young age. I have been reading so many of these detective novels that I know what to do. This is all very insane and illegal, isn't it? It is illegal and insane. I like insane. I believe you're a detective, not a licensed detective.
我一直在兼职做私家侦探。我以为你会更老一点。嗯，我年纪轻轻就进入了这个行业。我一直在读这么多侦探小说，我知道该怎么做。这一切都很疯狂且非法，不是吗？这是非法且疯狂的。我喜欢疯狂。我相信你是个侦探，但不是持证侦探。
No. I'm a writer. It sounds like your heart's in the right place. You cannot mess with other people's lives that you can barely lead your own life. I can help people. Are you delusional? Lady, I watched the first episode. I was so intrigued.
不。我是个作家。听起来你的心意是好的。你不能干涉别人的生活，你自己都过不好自己的生活。我可以帮助别人。你是不是有妄想症？女士，我看了第一集。我太感兴趣了。
I mean, it's kind of like mom detective, except he lives in New York and he's a struggling writer. I know. I know. It is like mom detectives, but I feel like his is more like serious cases. Like ours is going to be like, where did that stray construction cone go? Yes. Yes.
我的意思是，这有点像“妈妈侦探”，除了他住在纽约，是个挣扎中的作家。我知道。我知道。这确实像“妈妈侦探”，但我觉得他的更像是严肃的案件。就像我们的将是，那个流浪的施工锥去哪了？是的。是的。
He also, I think he's going to be solving the cases. Oh, well, we're never going to find the construction cone. We won't. Yes. So there's differences. There's still room for mom detectives. I won't be worried. Yeah.
我想他也会去破案。噢，好吧，我们永远也找不到那个施工锥。我们不会的。是的。所以有区别。仍然有“妈妈侦探”的空间。我不会担心的。是的。
Now we have the scene that is writer-director Brent Forrester's favorite scene. It is the scene where Andy approaches Aaron for his leads and she's hidden them. And she's like, colder, warmer, warmer. Oh, we used to do that as kids. And then if you were really going the wrong way, you'd be like, freezing, you're frostbite. Now you're a block of ice. Yes. But in this case, as he's approaching her chest, she's like, warmer, warmer.
现在我们有了编剧兼导演布伦特·福雷斯特最喜欢的一幕。这是安迪向艾琳索要他的潜在客户，而她把它们藏起来了。她说，冷了，热了，更热了。噢，我们小时候常那样做。然后如果你真的走错了方向，你会说，冻僵了，你冻伤了。现在你是一块冰块。是的。但在这种情况下，当他靠近她的胸部时，她说，更热了，更热了。
And he's like, really? And then she's like, lower. And he's like, ah. And then they're under her keyboard. She's such an odd bird. Well Brent sent in an audio clip breaking down the comedy elements of this scene. My favorite bit of comedy in the episode is Andy and Aaron doing the hotter, colder game at the reception desk.
他说，真的吗？然后她说，再低一点。他说，啊。然后它们在她的键盘下面。她真是个奇怪的人。布伦特发来一段音频剪辑，分析了这一幕的喜剧元素。我这一集中最喜欢的喜剧片段是安迪和艾琳在前台玩“更热、更冷”的游戏。
Why is it funny? Well, first of all, it's physical comedy, which so often is more powerful than the clever dialogue we try to create in the writer's room. There's also this very interesting dynamic, something I sometimes call unintentional self-revelation. OK, whenever a character reveals something that they'd rather hide, it's funny. So Andy misinterprets Aaron saying, hotter, hotter. As a sexual come on, he's revealing that he has sexual feelings towards Aaron. That's what's funny about it.
为什么它很有趣？好吧，首先，这是肢体喜剧，它通常比我们在编剧室里试图创造的聪明对话更有力量。还有一个非常有趣的动态，我有时称之为“无意的自我揭露”。好的，每当一个角色揭露了一些他们宁愿隐藏的事情时，它就很有趣。所以安迪误解了艾琳说的“更热，更热”。作为一个性暗示，他揭露了他对艾琳有性感觉。这就是它有趣的地方。
Notice also, though, that Aaron, by not understanding that she's doing double entendre, reveals unintentionally that she's a bit dumb and clueless. So it's a double unintentional self-revelation with physical comedy, guaranteed to be funny. It's comedy science. There you go. He should teach a course called comedy science. He should name his class comedy science. Comedy science.
不过也要注意，艾琳因为不明白她在用双关语，无意中揭露了她有点笨和无知。所以这是一个带有肢体喜剧的双重无意自我揭露，保证会很有趣。这是喜剧科学。给你。他应该开一门叫“喜剧科学”的课程。他应该把他的课命名为“喜剧科学”。喜剧科学。
Yes, Brent, because you just sort of spilled out that scene like in an equation, but it makes perfect sense. I think we just changed the name of Brent's class. Welcome to comedy science. I like it. Dwight is finally back from his very important sales call, and Jim is looking for a lead under a Lincoln town car. Because of a clue Michael gave him, Dwight thinks it's hilarious, he thinks Jim is the
是的，布伦特，因为你刚才就像一个方程式一样把那一幕倒了出来，但这完全说得通。我想我们刚刚改了布伦特课程的名字。欢迎来到喜剧科学。我喜欢它。德怀特终于从他非常重要的销售电话中回来了，吉姆正在林肯城市轿车下寻找潜在客户。因为迈克尔给他的线索，德怀特觉得这很滑稽，他认为吉姆是笑话的
butt of a joke, until he realizes the leads are here, and Michael didn't tell him. And let me tell you, he's going to go into that office hot. He sure is. Mm-hmm. He's going to try to get his leads from Kevin. He chokes Kevin. I know the scene. I mean, the scene.
笑柄，直到他意识到潜在客户在这里，而迈克尔没告诉他。让我告诉你，他会气冲冲地走进那个办公室。他肯定会。嗯哼。他会试图从凯文那里得到他的潜在客户。他掐住了凯文。我知道那一幕。我的意思是，那一幕。
They sold it so well. And then he's going to realize Kevin threw away the leads. He's going to look in the trash. It's empty. He's going to lick the trash bag. It's a brand new trash bag. Brand new. He knows from licking it.
他们演得太好了。然后他会意识到凯文把潜在客户扔掉了。他会去垃圾桶里找。它是空的。他会舔那个垃圾袋。这是一个全新的垃圾袋。全新的。他从舔它就知道。
Mm-hmm. So he's going to have to run down to the dumpster and dive in. He does like talk about parkour. He does like a whole flip into it. Well, according to Randy, they completely steam cleaned and fully sanitized that dumpster, and they put like, you know, something soft in there for him to land on. For him to land on, but that's rain, just jumping into that dumpster. I was so impressed.
嗯哼。所以他不得不跑下楼去垃圾箱里跳进去。他确实喜欢谈论跑酷。他确实做了一个完整的后空翻跳进去。好吧，据兰迪说，他们彻底蒸汽清洁并完全消毒了那个垃圾箱，他们还在里面放了点什么，你知道的，柔软的东西让他着陆。让他着陆，但那是雨，只是跳进那个垃圾箱。我印象太深刻了。
There's nothing in the dumpster, and he's like, ah, what day is it? And Kevin says, wait a second. It's Ghost Whisperer. Oh, yeah. So it's Friday. Trash day. Trash day. Jenna, this is sort of how, like, I feel like I give directions or no dates.
垃圾箱里什么都没有，他说，啊，今天是星期几？凯文说，等一下。是《灵感应》。噢，是的。所以是星期五。倒垃圾日。倒垃圾日。珍娜，这有点像，我觉得我给方向或不给日期的方式。
I'm kind of like Kevin. I'm like, oh, you turn left at the tree. The tree, you know, the one that has the wonky limb. Mm. I don't know what the street's called, but look for the wonky limb tree. And also Friday is Ghost Whisperer. Ghost Whisperer, for those of you who don't know, was an American supernatural television series which ran on CBS from 2005 to 2010.
我有点像凯文。我说，噢，你在那棵树左转。那棵树，你知道的，那棵有歪枝的树。嗯。我不知道那条街叫什么，但找那棵歪枝树。而且星期五是《灵感应》。《灵感应》，对于那些不知道的人来说，是一部美国超自然电视剧，从2005年到2010年在哥伦比亚广播公司播出。
I didn't know the show, but here is the summary. Okay. It stars Jennifer Love-Hewitt. That's right. She plays Melinda Gordon. The series follows her. She has the ability to see and communicate with ghosts while trying to live as normal a life as possible.
我不知道这个节目，但这是摘要。好的。它由詹妮弗·洛芙·休伊特主演。没错。她扮演梅琳达·戈登。该系列讲述了她。她有能力看到并与鬼魂交流，同时试图过上尽可能正常的生活。
She is married and owns an antique store called, same as it never was. And Melinda helps the earthbound spirits resolve their problems and cross over into the light. But her tasks are sometimes difficult. It was very popular. This I know. It had a lot of big names in it. Oh, yeah.
她结婚了，拥有一家名为“Same as it Never Was”的古董店。梅琳达帮助那些被困在地球上的灵魂解决他们的问题并跨越到光明中。但她的任务有时很困难。它非常受欢迎。这一点我知道。里面有很多大牌明星。噢，是的。
Yeah. Well, it's apparently one of Kevin's favorite shows. Well, when they realize it's Friday, they realize that's the day that the trash truck comes. Michael's going to try to run after the truck as it goes down the street. We had a fan question from Maria B in New York. Did you have to rent that garbage truck that Michael ran after? Good question.
是的。好吧，这显然是凯文最喜欢的节目之一。好吧，当他们意识到是星期五时，他们意识到那是垃圾车来的日子。迈克尔试图在垃圾车沿街行驶时追赶它。我们收到了来自纽约玛丽亚·B的粉丝提问。你必须租那辆迈克尔追赶的垃圾车吗？好问题。
Randy said yes. Our transportation coordinator rented a trash truck from Cinema Vehicle Services. And the driver of the trash truck was Mike Stork, who you remember was our limo driver in shareholders meeting. Yep. He's driving stuff for us. He is. Did you notice at 13 minutes, 41 seconds, when Michael is trying to recruit everyone,
兰迪说是的。我们的交通协调员从电影车辆服务公司租了一辆垃圾车。垃圾车的司机是迈克·斯托克，你还记得他是我们在股东大会上的豪华轿车司机吗？是的。他在为我们开车。他是。你注意到在13分41秒，当迈克尔试图招募每个人时，
you know, we got to go to the dumpster now, guys. Who's with me? Yeah. Right? His suit jacket, when the sun hits it just right, looks purple. No. Yes. Look at this.
你知道，我们现在得去垃圾箱了，伙计们。谁跟我一起？是的。对吧？他的西装外套，当阳光正好照在上面时，看起来是紫色的。不。是的。看看这个。
I took a screen grab. Purple sun suit. It looked navy to me for the rest of the episode. But when the sun hit it just right, wait till you see this, it has a little, a little sheen to it. I couldn't help but laugh because I thought to our costume department and how they put such detail that Michael's suits were like a certain material. Mm-hmm.
我截了一张图。紫色太阳西装。在这一集的其余部分，它对我来说看起来是海军蓝的。但当阳光正好照在上面时，等着看这个，它有一点，一点光泽。我忍不住笑了，因为我想到了我们的服装部门，以及他们如何投入如此多的细节，使迈克尔的西装像某种材料。嗯哼。
Look at, like, tell me you see purple. Oh, yeah. Yeah. That has some purple undertones. And when the sun hit it, for sure. Mm-hmm. So here's the thing. The only person who's willing to go to the dump with Michael is Dwight.
看，就像，告诉我你看到了紫色。噢，是的。是的。那确实有一些紫色的底色。当阳光照在上面时，肯定有。嗯哼。所以事情是这样的。唯一愿意和迈克尔一起去垃圾场的人是德怀特。
Yeah. Dwight says, you know what? I'm going to go with you because you'll probably mess it up. Yeah. So we go to our dump that's really in our warehouse. And I have to say, I loved all these scenes with Michael and Dwight at the dump. I did too. I loved it when they said, well, this place is really gone to hell.
是的。德怀特说，你知道吗？我要和你一起去，因为你可能会搞砸。是的。所以我们去了我们仓库里真正的垃圾场。我必须说，我喜欢迈克尔和德怀特在垃圾场的所有场景。我也喜欢。我喜欢他们说，好吧，这个地方真的变得一团糟了。
Yeah. Like, what did it start out like? Yes. Well, while they're at the dump, Michael says, Dwight, you've changed. You suddenly care so much about money. Yeah. And I love this runner where Dwight says, you know, he'd be doing so much better without Michael.
是的。就像，它刚开始是什么样子的？是的。好吧，当他们在垃圾场时，迈克尔说，德怀特，你变了。你突然变得这么在乎钱了。是的。我喜欢这个情节，德怀特说，你知道，没有迈克尔他会做得更好。
He could have taken that job at Home Depot where he could be number two at Home Depot. But instead, he went with Michael and now look where they are. They start throwing trash at each other, so much trash. Big trash. Big spool. Mm-hmm. That's my favorite part of the scene is all of the spool, quote unquote, throwing. We actually had a fan catch from Michelle G in Oregon.
他本可以接受家得宝的那份工作，在那里他可以成为家得宝的二把手。但相反，他跟着迈克尔，现在看看他们在哪。他们开始互相扔垃圾，太多的垃圾。大垃圾。大线轴。嗯哼。这是我最喜欢的一幕，所有的线轴，引用“扔”。我们实际上收到了来自俄勒冈州米歇尔·G的粉丝发现。
Hi, office ladies, every time I watch this episode, I am oddly fascinated by the giant spool at the dump. Was this in the script? No. The spool was not in the script. It just specified that they would throw trash. I want you to know it's 17 minutes and 23 seconds. There is a second spool.
嗨，办公室女士们，每次我看这一集，我都奇怪地被垃圾场的巨大线轴所吸引。这是剧本里的吗？不。线轴不在剧本里。它只是指定他们会扔垃圾。我想让你知道是17分23秒。有第二个线轴。
What? There were two spools. There's two spools, guys, one that they're throwing at each other and one, if you look behind Dwight, spool number two. Second spool. Mm-hmm. Well, Jenna, have you ever been to a dump? I have not ever toured a dump.
什么？有两个线轴。伙计们有两个线轴，一个他们互相扔，另一个，如果你看德怀特后面，二号线轴。第二个线轴。嗯哼。好吧，珍娜，你去过垃圾场吗？我从来没有参观过垃圾场。
My uncle Carl used to drive a dump truck. Okay. And my sisters and I would love to ride in it with him as a big old truck. Mm-hmm. And we went to the local dump many times. I have questions before you even get to the dump. Okay. Was it a trash truck that automatically put the trash in the back or did he have to get
我叔叔卡尔过去常开垃圾车。好的。我和我的姐妹们喜欢和他一起坐在那辆大旧卡车里。嗯哼。我们去过当地的垃圾场很多次。在你到达垃圾场之前，我有问题。好的。那是自动把垃圾放进后面的垃圾车，还是他必须下车
out and do it manually, because like when I was a kid, they didn't have the ones that had the little arm. No, no, no. You had to get out and throw the trash in. This was like old school. You're correct. This was before the fancy trucks that have the arm that comes out and picks something up.
手动操作，因为像我小时候，他们没有那种有小手臂的。不，不，不。你必须下车把垃圾扔进去。这是老派的。你是对的。这是在那些有伸出来捡东西的手臂的豪华卡车之前。
Okay. Yeah. See, I was curious because I think if you were a kid, it would be fun if he let you operate the little arm. Oh, yeah. Right? That would have been really cool. No, this truck didn't have that.
好的。是的。看，我很好奇，因为我想如果你是个孩子，如果他让你操作那个小手臂会很有趣。噢，是的。对吧？那会很酷。不，这辆卡车没有那个。
Okay. Predates that. I was fascinated by trash and I guess I always have been and for this episode, I have some trash facts for you. I love trash facts. So according to the internet, and I looked on a few different sites and most of these surveys were done between 2019 and 2020. Okay.
好的。在那之前。我对垃圾很着迷，我想我一直都是，对于这一集，我有一些垃圾事实给你。我喜欢垃圾事实。所以根据互联网，我在几个不同的网站上查过，大多数这些调查是在2019年到2020年之间完成的。好的。
Okay. So the average American produces 4.5 pounds of waste every single day. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Every day? Every day. Four and a half pounds. That's the average American. However, the amount of trash that is going into our dumps right now is at its lowest
好的。所以普通美国人每天产生4.5磅的垃圾。等等，等等，等等，等等。每天？每天。四点五磅。那是普通美国人。然而，现在进入我们垃圾场的垃圾量处于自1960年以来的最低
level since 1960. Oh, do we know why that is? I think there's- Is it recycling? I think we have these initiatives now for recycling and reusing. Here are the three things that make up more than half of the garbage in all of the United States landfills. Okay. Food waste, plastics, and paper products.
水平。噢，我们知道为什么吗？我想有——是回收吗？我想我们现在有这些回收和再利用的倡议。以下是构成美国所有垃圾填埋场中超过一半垃圾的三件事。好的。食物垃圾、塑料和纸制品。
Michigan is the state with the most trash per capita, with Indiana and Illinois ranking second and third. That's per capita, right? California has more landfills than any other state in the nation, more than twice as many in fact as every other state except Texas. Wow. Yeah. The largest landfill currently in America is the Apex Regional Las Vegas, Nevada landfill
密歇根州是人均垃圾最多的州，印第安纳州和伊利诺伊州排名第二和第三。那是人均，对吧？加利福尼亚州的垃圾填埋场比全国任何其他州都多，事实上是除德克萨斯州外所有其他州的两倍多。哇。是的。美国目前最大的垃圾填埋场是内华达州拉斯维加斯的Apex区域垃圾填埋场
with 2,200 acres. Wow. I'm not done. That's me turning my paper. I hope you're still with me. I'm on the edge of my seat. All right. Jenna, the next part is a little bit of a quiz.
有2200英亩。哇。我还没说完。那是我在翻纸。希望你还在听。我坐在座位的边缘。好的。珍娜，下一部分是一个小测验。
I'm going to ask you how long it takes different types of garbage to decompose. Okay. Okay. Should we get our quiz music? Oh. I'm not going to get any of these right. Sam, you're welcome to play. All right.
我要问你不同类型的垃圾分解需要多长时间。好的。好的。我们应该拿我们的测验音乐吗？噢。我一个都答不对。萨姆，欢迎你播放。好的。
First question, you guys. How long do you think it takes paper to decompose since we are the people's paper people? I'll say two years. I'll say, I like that answer, two years. Two to six weeks. Oh. Okay. Two to six weeks.
第一个问题，伙计们。既然我们是人民的造纸人，你认为纸分解需要多长时间？我会说两年。我会说，我喜欢那个答案，两年。两到六周。噢。好的。两到六周。
The pessimists in both of us are coming out early. Second question, how long would it take a cigarette butt or a wool sock to decompose? Well, first of all, I am surprised that cigarette butt and wool sock decompose at the same rate. I know. They're lumped together here in this survey. But I'm going to say five years. This time I'll join you. I'll say five years.
我们俩的悲观主义者都过早地显露出来了。第二个问题，烟头或羊毛袜分解需要多长时间？好吧，首先，我很惊讶烟头和羊毛袜的分解速度是一样的。我知道。它们在这个调查中被归为一类。但我会说五年。这次我加入你。我会说五年。
One to five years. Yay. I got that one. Very nice. Learning curve. Okay. Batteries. Oh.
一到五年。耶。我答对了那个。非常好。学习曲线。好的。电池。噢。
Oh. Aren't we not supposed to even throw those away? Yeah. 10 years? I'm going to go big and say 20. 100 years. 100 years. Yep.
噢。我们不是连那些都不应该扔掉吗？是的。10年？我要说大一点，说20年。100年。100年。是的。
How about a leather shoe? These seem so specific to the person that wrote this. I'm going to say, first of all, leather is an animal. Uh-huh. It's been treated. Seven years. I'm going to go big again. It's a 15.
皮鞋怎么样？这些对写这篇文章的人来说似乎太具体了。我会说，首先，皮革是动物。嗯哼。它经过处理。七年。我又要说大一点了。是15年。
25 to 40 years. Uh-huh. For a leather shoe. Uh-huh. Styrofoam cup. 100 years. Yeah. I'm going to go big and say that one.
25到40年。嗯哼。对于一只皮鞋。嗯哼。泡沫塑料杯。100年。是的。我要说大一点。
It's 100 years as well. 50 years. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. A disposable diaper or a plastic bottle. Same category.
它也是100年。50年。好的。好的。好的。好的。一次性尿布或塑料瓶。同一类别。
If that was the other one, 150? 75 years. 450 years. For every diaper and every plastic bottle is 400 years. 450 years. Good God. Uh-huh. All right.
如果那是另一个，150年？75年。450年。对于每一个尿布和每一个塑料瓶是400年。450年。天哪。嗯哼。好的。
A credit card. Just a credit card. Your bank card. 200. I know. Are we just moving up the ladder? I'm saying 60 years on the credit card. 1000 years.
信用卡。只是一张信用卡。你的银行卡。200年。我知道。我们只是在爬梯子吗？我说信用卡是60年。1000年。
No. What? What? That's what it says. My credit card decomposes more slowly than my leather shoe? Yes. Oh my gosh. And then a glass bottle.
不。什么？什么？这就是它说的。我的信用卡分解得比我的皮鞋还慢？是的。噢，天哪。然后是玻璃瓶。
A glass bottle shouldn't be in the trash. You should have recycled that. Yeah. A glass bottle takes one million years. Oh my gosh. I know. I believe you. This is according to this survey.
玻璃瓶不应该在垃圾里。你应该回收它。是的。玻璃瓶需要一百万年。噢，天哪。我知道。我相信你。这是根据这个调查。
So what I'm hearing is my battery powered leather diapers that I've been throwing away. With the glass insert. That you bought with your credit card. Which every time I make a purchase, you guys throw your credit card away after you make a purchase, right? Always. Always. But think about though, you get a new card, you cut the other one up, you put it in the
所以我听到的是我一直扔掉的电池供电的皮尿布。带有玻璃插件的。你用信用卡买的。每次我购物时，你们在购物后都会扔掉信用卡，对吧？总是。总是。但想想看，你得到一张新卡，你剪掉旧的那张，你把它放进
trash. Yeah. So, I mean, trash statistics guys, it's mind blowing. Angela, I loved your trash facts. Thank you. I am going to put the link to this article I read in the stories so you can look at it yourself. There's a diagram here with objects and how long it takes for them to decompose.
垃圾里。是的。所以，我的意思是，垃圾统计数据伙计们，这太令人震惊了。安吉拉，我喜欢你的垃圾事实。谢谢。我会把我读的这篇文章的链接放在故事里，这样你可以自己看。这里有一个图表，上面有物体以及它们分解需要多长时间。
Wow. I will say this, my trash facts were based on studies in the United States. So I don't know where the biggest landfills are globally, but those are your stats for America. I loved all of them. And I believe if you don't follow this, recyclops comes for you. Yes. That's right.
哇。我会说这个，我的垃圾事实是基于美国的研究。所以我不知道全球最大的垃圾填埋场在哪里，但这些是你在美国的统计数据。我喜欢所有这些。我相信如果你不遵守这个，回收怪兽(Recyclops)就会来找你。是的。没错。
My goodness. Well, let's see. Where are we? Oh, we're in the break room with Jim and the sales team and they are trying to figure out what can they do to kind of get their coworkers back into their good graces. Maybe they could share their commission. Jim texts Pam, she suggests getting them new iPods, which by the way have been discontinued. You cannot buy iPods anymore.
天哪。好吧，让我们看看。我们在哪？噢，我们在休息室和吉姆以及销售团队在一起，他们正试图弄清楚他们能做些什么来让同事们重新回到他们的好感中。也许他们可以分享他们的佣金。吉姆给帕姆发短信，她建议给他们买新iPod，顺便说一下，这些已经停产了。你买不到iPod了。
It was just in the news, which, you know, podcasts are named after the iPod because they were a thing that you could listen to on your iPod, they are no longer going to exist. Craziness. Wow. Yeah. They were such a big deal for so long. Like if you got an iPod for Christmas, yes. Talk about old tech and Phyllis has a super sassy line.
这刚刚出现在新闻中，你知道，播客是以iPod命名的，因为它们是你可以在iPod上听的东西，它们将不再存在。疯狂。哇。是的。它们在很长一段时间里都是一件大事。就像如果你圣诞节得到一个iPod，是的。谈论旧技术，菲利斯有一句超级时髦的台词。
She does. She says if they don't have an iPod by now, they don't really want one. She's not getting people iPods. Andy is going to text Erin and she is going to suggest shells from a far away beach might make everyone happy. Oh, Erin, has she been on a beach vacation? I don't know. She's definitely wanting to go on one and get a shell.
她有。她说如果他们现在还没有iPod，他们就不真的想要一个。她不会给人们买iPod。安迪要给艾琳发短信，她会建议来自遥远海滩的贝壳可能会让每个人都开心。噢，艾琳，她去过海滩度假吗？我不知道。她肯定想去那里并得到一个贝壳。
She is. I want to point out more old tech in this episode. We should call this episode old tech. Look at all the cell phones in this scene. There are no smartphones when Jim Tech's Pam and Andy Tech's Erin, they have to flip open their phone. At least they're not texting a beeper. That's true.
她是。我想指出这一集中更多的旧技术。我们应该把这一集称为“旧技术”。看看这一幕里的所有手机。当吉姆给帕姆发短信，安迪给艾琳发短信时，没有智能手机，他们必须翻开手机。至少他们不是在给寻呼机发短信。那是真的。
That was like the pilot. I know. This episode should be called old tech slash please recycle. It's so true. Well they decide in the end that they are going to share their commissions with the rest of the staff. I can't believe they got Stanley to agree to that. No kidding.
那就像试播集。我知道。这一集应该叫“旧技术/请回收”。太真实了。好吧，他们最终决定分享他们的佣金给其他员工。我不敢相信他们让斯坦利同意了这一点。别开玩笑了。
The fight at the dump has finally come to an end. It was real sloppy and messy. The fellas are real tired. Yeah, we had a fan question from Emilyn B and Calgary. What did Michael spill on himself in the dump scene? Oh yeah, that was gross. It was just water. Phew.
垃圾场的战斗终于结束了。它真的很邋遢和混乱。伙计们真的很累。是的，我们收到了来自卡尔加里Emilyn B的粉丝提问。迈克尔在垃圾场那一幕把什么洒在自己身上了？噢，是的，那很恶心。那只是水。呼。
They finally start to have some common ground. They sit down, Dwight Marvel's at the trash and says no other animal on earth could do this, except maybe beavers. Yeah. I feel like this should have been NBC's green episode. No kidding. Recycle. Michael and Dwight make up and Michael has a vision.
他们终于开始有一些共同点。他们坐下来，德怀特对垃圾感到惊叹，说地球上没有其他动物能做到这一点，除了海狸。是的。我觉得这应该是NBC的绿色环保集。别开玩笑了。回收。迈克尔和德怀特和好了，迈克尔有一个愿景。
It's of a single flower sticking up through the trash. And together they come up with a caption. Dwight says hope grows and Michael says in a dump. Hope grows in a dump. So many people have made hope grows in a dump posters, t-shirts, just pages and pages. I was scrolling. They're all wonderful. Hope grows in a dump.
那是一朵从垃圾中伸出来的单花。他们一起想出了一个标题。德怀特说“希望生长”，迈克尔说“在垃圾场里”。希望在垃圾场里生长。很多人制作了“希望在垃圾场里生长”的海报、T恤，只是页面和页面。我在滚动。它们都很棒。希望在垃圾场里生长。
We say hope in a frame. Hope in a frame. But now I'm going to say hope grows in a dump. You know what the message is, you guys? Hope lives in many places. You just have to believe. Yeah. I mean, it's a nice message.
我们说“框架里的希望”。框架里的希望。但现在我要说“希望在垃圾场里生长”。你知道信息是什么吗，伙计们？希望生活在许多地方。你只需要相信。是的。我的意思是，这是一个很好的信息。
Back at the office, the salespeople have gathered their co-workers in the conference room and they have a bunch of treats. Yeah, like pastries and coffee. They are about to announce their plan to share their commission when Oscar says, you know what? This is really nice, guys. Yeah. Classy move.
回到办公室，销售人员把他们的同事聚集在会议室里，他们有很多款待。是的，比如糕点和咖啡。他们正要宣布他们分享佣金的计划时，奥斯卡说，你知道吗？这真的很好，伙计们。是的。优雅的举动。
And they all realize, oh my gosh, it just took some pastry. And Stanley comes in and he's like, you better print, and they're like, ah-bah-bah-bah-bah-bah-bah-bah. And Phyllis is like, they've accepted our gesture of treats and nothing more, something like that. I can't remember exactly, but it's really good. We had a fan catch from Bethi in Ohio at 19 minutes and 36 seconds. It looks like Phyllis briefly breaks character after Kevin's line. When we walked in here, we were all prepared to tell you to go to hell.
他们都意识到，噢，天哪，这只需要一些糕点。斯坦利进来了，他说，你最好打印，他们说，啊-巴-巴-巴-巴-巴-巴-巴。菲利斯说，他们接受了我们的款待姿态，仅此而已，类似那样的话。我不记得确切的了，但它真的很好。我们收到了来自俄亥俄州Bethi在19分36秒的粉丝发现。看起来菲利斯在凯文的台词后短暂地打破了角色。当我们走进这里时，我们都准备好告诉你们去死吧。
Well, Beth, I looked at this and I don't think Phyllis is breaking. When you all rewatch it, check it out. Let us know what you think. But I think Phyllis is just smiling because she's pleased with herself. Michael and Dwight return triumphant. Even though they haven't found the leads, they have all kinds of stuff from the dump. They've got a giant big purple beanbag. They said they're going to put it in the break room.
好吧，贝丝，我看了这个，我不认为菲利斯打破了角色。当你们所有人重看时，检查一下。让我们知道你们怎么想。但我认为菲利斯只是在微笑，因为她对自己很满意。迈克尔和德怀特凯旋而归。即使他们没有找到潜在客户，他们也从垃圾场得到了各种各样的东西。他们有一个巨大的紫色豆袋。他们说他们要把它放在休息室。
Where? Where are they putting it in the break room? There's no room in there. You know, I really wish, though, like in the few episodes after this one, it would have been in the corner. I would have loved to see that call back. It's so true. Well, this episode ends at the dump.
在哪？他们把它放在休息室的哪里？那里没有空间。你知道，我真的希望，就像在这一集之后的几集里，它会在角落里。我很想看到那个呼应。太真实了。好吧，这一集在垃圾场结束。
And guess what? Some hope is going to grow there. Erin and Andy kiss at the dump, their first kiss. Hope in a dump. Mm-hmm. Rid it, did it do. I know. It was so sweet.
猜猜怎么着？一些希望会在那里生长。艾琳和安迪在垃圾场接吻，他们的初吻。垃圾场里的希望。嗯哼。Rid it, did it do。我知道。太甜了。
So how cute is it when Erin gives Andy her coat because Andy's chilly? And it doesn't fit him. At all. Aw, that's new leads. Well, thank you so much to Brent Forrester for sending in audio clips and always being there for us to talk about these episodes with. And to you guys for sending in your questions and comments. Thank you, Randy, for giving me that great location breakdown on the old dump.
所以当艾琳把她的外套给安迪因为安迪冷时，这有多可爱？而且它根本不合身。一点也不。噢，那是新的潜在客户。好吧，非常感谢布伦特·福雷斯特发来音频剪辑，并一直在这里让我们谈论这些剧集。也感谢你们发送你们的问题和评论。谢谢你，兰迪，给我那个关于旧垃圾场的伟大位置分析。
Yeah. And guess you guys, you know, recycle and reuse because it takes a long time for things to decompose. And next week, we're going to go to Happy Hour, yeah, which should be fun. Date Mike. Oh, date Mike. He goes and he changes his clothes, he puts on that hat backwards, oh, date Mike. Take care, you guys.
是的。猜猜你们，你知道，回收和再利用，因为东西分解需要很长时间。下周，我们要去“欢乐时光”，是的，那应该很有趣。约会迈克。噢，约会迈克。他去换了衣服，他把那顶帽子反戴着，噢，约会迈克。保重，伙计们。
We'll see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com.
我们下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是安斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。如需无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。
For a free one month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如需在Stitcher Premium免费试用一个月，请使用代码：Office。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。